[Music]
wow
let's give it up for our 46th president
of the united states joe biden
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right
thank you all so much
it's my great honor to be with our
president he began his public service
career in county government new council
county delaware council
he's community-minded business focused
and has a human service heart he
understands county government
he went to bed for us for the historic
investments of counties with american
rescue plan
additionally he was with us every step
of the way for the bipartisan
infrastructure plan
1.2 trillion dollars
roads
bridges
trails
sewer
he understands counties at the very root
grassroots level
thank you president biden
we are grateful
for such a strong partner in the white
house
it is my distinct honor to introduce to
all of you our friend the 46th president
of these united states joe biden thank
you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you
folks uh
my name is joe biden
and i used to be a county councilman
[Music]
[Applause]
and i ran for the senate because it was
too damn hard being on the council
it's me
all
commissioner
tyra johnson of dekalb county georgia
thank you for your leadership
i also want to thank all the folks
working so hard here and washington
hilton to make this conference possible
thank you all very much
and you want to know how seriously i
take the role you play
on the front lines in this country
just look at who i asked to come with
you you said you wanted to know what's
going on i sent you the whole damn
administration
[Applause]
yeah secretary's three secretaries
an administrator uh
reagan epa gene sperling leading the
rescue plan implementation
mitch landry who's leading the
implementation of the infrastructure law
and you all know julie rodriguez my
director of intergovernmental affairs
and
along with a number of other key
deputies and leading my economic
strategy
look i want to recognize my home county
executive matt meyer so i can go back
home matt thank you
thank you
[Applause]
matt's doing one heck of a job and i'm
sure he's told you the story i heard
that
my time in the county council you know i
uh i don't want you all but commissioner
councilman whichever your title is you
knock on the door and say
my name's joe biden i'm a candidate for
the county council they look at you like
okay
and you're the one you're wondering what
the county council does aren't you
well it affects your lives more than
anybody else's
i know it really does you were involved
in everything
when i constituted a call
uh she said uh
i represented a
uh we had
we have one county that has 60 in the
state's population
and we had six councilmen so a
councilman's district was
seven times bigger than a house member
and uh in the in the state house and
three times bigger than a state senator
and i represented a middle class
district to a working class district but
there was one very wealthy neighborhood
i got a call one night
a woman said to me obviously not of the
same persuasion as i was politically
called me and said there's a dead dog on
my lawn
and i said yes ma'am i said have you
called the county he said yes they're
not here
and i said well i'll get him in the
morning she said i want it removed now i
pay your salary
so i went over
[Laughter]
i picked it up
she said i want it out of my front yard
i put it on her doorstep
[Laughter]
but i've gotten much better since then
so know from personal experience how
hard the job you have is people
people having a phone or you know are
not afraid to use that phone i i used to
give out my phone number can't do that
anymore they don't even allow me to have
a phone anymore
but i also know you work often on the
basis of what
other people
when they've lost faith they have faith
they lose faith in government you're
there you represent the front lines of
public service not hyperbole
that's why i was elected one of the
first calls i made
was to your board of directors
and i reminded judge gary moore your
past president that this administration
includes the president vice president
for both former county officials
and i promise i'll always have you as a
partner with us
the partnership is critical when we pass
the american rescue plan
most significant investment in the
country's local governments in american
history and also inherited a tough
situation in 2020 but after an
incredibly difficult year
local and state governments have added
448 000 new jobs in 2021 the strongest
growth in 20 years
and you know uh it's uh
it's amazing what you all do i really
mean it i'm not being solicitous
after a year disruption for our kids
we were able to add education jobs in
2021
more than
more than any other year on record
you've got county law enforcement
officers first responders back in the
job so ambulance could arrive on time
communities could be kept safe
and the big reason why america's
recovery has led the world is because of
all of you
and why my first year in office more
jobs were created than ever anytime in
american history 6.6 million jobs
you
and folks look
we had the strongest economic growth in
nearly 40 years
5.7
increase in the gdp unemployment rate
dropped more than any time any year in
american history
child poverty dropped by 40
more than any year in american history
as folks
new business applications grew at a
faster rate than any year on record
the rescue plan also was the first major
relief bill to get directly to counties
because here's what i learned
when i was a county councilman if you
get money for a state
what happens is it goes through the
state legislature
and guess what
well i want to make sure the money goes
directly to the counties
directly to counties no really
we allocated 350 billion dollars of
state and local budgets
we made sure that one billion of that
went straight to the counties and cities
and look i know how much it matters it
really matters giving you uh giving you
the ability the flexibility the control
to meet
both the short-term and long-term
challenges you face which by the way
even i'm not being critical of a state
legislatures or to or others but people
don't know
the full responsibility and
and that you all have
even other elected officials
i mean i'm not being solicitous it's
just true
and by the way
that rescue plan is still delivering
i urge all of you to use the flexibility
we built into that law and spend those
funds wisely
to build a future around working people
who make up the communities you run put
these funds to work to keep people on
the job
connect people with better jobs and
providing retention bonuses
for teachers and bus drivers
like howard county maryland did
adding health care centers and training
new child care workers like uh i hope i
pronounced the deschutes county oregon
as i could
where are you scott
well what you did matters
helping unemployed parents get back to
work by covering child care costs like
oakland county michigan did reducing gun
crime by retaining police officers like
dekalb county did in georgia
expanding community violence prevention
programs but king county did in
washington
ensuring people get the full benefit of
one of the most consequential tax cuts
for working families in our history
we expanded the child care tax credit
earned income tax credit included in the
rescue plan
in the past if you paid
taxes and you had a good income you
could deduct two thousand dollars per
child if you were making 200 grand a
year and you had three kids you got to
deduct six thousand bucks off your off
of the taxes you owed that's fair
but guess what
if you're making minimum wage
and you had four kids
you didn't get anything
it wasn't refundable you didn't pay
eight thousand dollars in taxes there
wasn't what you could read you couldn't
reduce your taxes so we made sure it was
refundable
because guess what
it's just as hard
for a firefighter or a teacher or a cop
who was the benefit of that tax break to
raise his kids is for a wealthy person
to raise their kids
well and
by the way
it's not a criticism of the wealthy it's
just to think about it think about it it
was well intended originally when when
the child care tax credit
when the tax credit existed or early on
because she said well we got to give a
break for raising kids
but our members to drive my dad nuts
because we had four kids it was a lot
less it was less than a thousand bucks
then
but you know if you're making what was
12 000 bucks a year that was like making
40 now or 50.
you're making that kind of money you
didn't have any taxes you could deduct
it from
so there wasn't any benefit for your
kids
look that's why the american rescue plan
we didn't expand the amount
this we expanded the amount but even if
we don't expand the amount middle-class
tax cut
we made it refundable
so you get paid back what you would have
had to pay
and
which which you got to deduct if you
made more money
so the money you go directly into your
pocket help you with your kids
that's why i'm so thankful for counties
like salt lake county and miami-dade
county created programs to help lower
income folks who typically don't even
file taxes because they're below minimum
wage they don't have any income
to get the assistance they need but they
have to file in order to get the
assistance
you all reached out and said look you
have a benefit coming
but you got to file taxes and you help
them do it
and i used to have a friend who was a
great basketball player
back in the days when providence had
great teams
providence college no i mean they had
they had some superstars at the time his
name was pete mclaughlin
and he wasn't uh he passed away but it
wasn't the uh
he used to say he wasn't the sharpest
academic candle on table but he knew
what was going on
and he knew how to actually he said you
know
he had an expression
you got to know how to know
i can take you into the greatest library
in the world the library of congress you
don't know how to read the card catalog
is useless to you
you got to know how to know
you're helping people know how to know
how to get into their what they need
it's all about making sure people
have more economic difficulty raising
their families can finally get a benefit
the wealthier people get the tax burdens
and the child tax credit but look
another thing that funding
can support thanks to the bipartisan
infrastructure bill is jobs
it's going to create
millions several million jobs
folks look it took a long time a lot of
administration but we finally passed
a bipartisan infrastructure bill
everybody
we finally ended infrastructure week we
got something done
everybody knew america was falling
behind in infrastructure
after years of dead ends and broken
promises we came together democrats and
republicans we did something about it
not only has infrastructure week finally
arrived
you can look forward to an
infrastructure decade that's what this
is for ten years
just ninety-two 92 days after i signed
the law it's already making a tangible
difference
we announced billions of funding
allocations
to put people to work in good paying
jobs
cleaning up rivers in ohio chemical
plants in florida dozens of other sites
bolstering the energy grid
with the stronger transmission lines and
towers modernizing bridges like the one
i visited in crafting county up in new
hampshire where the weight restrictions
could force school buses and fire trucks
to go 10 miles out of the way to get the
other side of the river
and capping and plugging tens of
thousands of orphaned oil wells and gas
wells
that continue to spew methane
which is a deadly
for the environment
creating jobs as good as the folks who
dug those wells in the first place
with the same salaries
this is only the beginning
hundreds of billions of new investments
are on the way
now it's time for the counties to get
ready
you don't have to wait until the
projects start
you can use the resources from the
american rescue plan now
you're going to need welders pipefitters
advanced manufacturers ready to take on
those jobs
it takes training to do those jobs well
and that's why union workers are the
best in the world because they actually
get the job done cheaper because they
don't waste any time
but you can start
i know you all know but you can start
those rescue plan funds now
by building pathways to better jobs
through union-based apprentice programs
and on-the-job training
like you know
maricopa county and arizona where
they're using american rescue plan funds
to help young workers develop in-demand
technical skills you know what the
county's going to need
community colleges are doing it as well
boone county campbell county kenton
county kentucky where you're expanding
high-speed internet to nearly 100 000
homes and businesses
you know how many times you ride by a
mcdonald's parking lot in the middle of
the pandemic and see people out there
sitting the mom and dad
tying into the network so their kids
could do their homework remotely this
united states of america for god's sake
cook county illinois where you're using
rescue plan funds to work with the
southland metal sub
helping workers prepare to take on
manufacturing infrastructure jobs and
strengthen the supply chains in the
heartland
rescue plan funds
we deliver to your county to your
counties
they can help each of you build a strong
diverse workforce you'll need to take up
and take up on these infrastructure jobs
so that where
more families can deal themselves in to
this booming economy
the truth is
we have an incredible opportunity ahead
of us
that's not hyperbole we really do
we still have a lot of work to do to put
together what we've proven that
we can get big things done in this
country bipartisan
and we know the challenges still remain
we're still fighting a deadly virus
we still need more people to get
vaccinated and boosted
but thanks to our your partnership
we've gone from 2 million people
vaccinated when i got elected to 215
million people vaccinated
and
and again i'm not being solicitous
you've been critical partners since day
one
on masking texas texting vaccinations
standing strong against misinformation
and sometimes even even withstanding
shameful personal attacks
through it all
you've led with patriotism and resolve
and you've saved lives
another challenge we face is even easing
the burden on working families this
there's real inflation
if you're a working-class family it
hurts
that's why i build a better plan what
it's all about look families are getting
clobbered
by the cost of everyday things
you know i know the gas and food prices
are up
we're working to bring them down i grew
up in a family
where the price of the pump was felt in
the kitchen
everybody knew everybody felt it i
understand
are necessities but they're not the
totality with family needs
so while we work on supply chains and we
work on bringing down the cost of the
things that we're talking about have
gone up so high
we still have other ways we can reduce
the burden on working class families
they still have to pay for child care
families can spend as much as fourteen
thousand dollars a year in some part of
the country for child care
my plan the cost of child care for
working families will cost seven percent
of your income no more
that helps millions of parents
especially women get back to work 20
million of them
by the
it
way
up paying for itself and we're back to
work paying taxes
look
we still pay for we we still have to pay
for prescription drugs you want to
benefit a family
reduce the cost of the prescription
drugs they have to pay in america
in america
we pay the highest price for precision
drugs in the world of any developed
nation in the world
about two to three times what other
countries pay
let me give you a sec i can give you
hundreds of examples let me give you one
one anti-cancer drug to treat leukemia
and lymphoma
that costs 14 000 a month in the united
states
that same exact drug by the same drug
company the same company
that drug sold in france cost six
thousand dollars
six thousand dollars
those who live on the canadian border
you know you cross the border you can
buy the same drug for a hell of a lot
less than you can buy in the united
states same manufacturer
or take insulin
the cost of drug companies to provide
insulin a violent insulin
cost less than ten dollars to make
but there are many families like
families i met last week on culpepper
virginia
paying 300 per vial
for medicine they need every single day
type 1 by diabetes
if they have good health care coverage
this family does
but they still have to pay five thousand
six hundred dollars for prescriptions
before their insurance kicks in
think about that
two hundred thousand american children
with type one diabetes
think about being one of those parents
you don't have insurance
but you know your child to live needs
that insulin
how do you look at child eye
when you know the income
or you don't have you don't have the
insurance
what do you do
not only are you wherever your child may
die
but you're strict of your dignity
you're stripping your sense of who you
are
not being able to afford that child's
needs
look
we can cap the cost of insulins at 35 a
month
drug companies will still make money
[Applause]
let me digress just for a moment
i started the cancer moonshot which i
worked very hard on in
the
administration the administration i
served in last
and
i held conferences all over the country
with literally thousands of people
at the same time
on doing it virtually
and after one of them
i got the
12 largest drug companies in one room
and i said
if you found a cure
for
a particular cancer and i named the
cancer
i said what amount of money do you think
you should be able to charge for that
drug
they said whatever the market will bear
and i said well you know
many places like germany
you can get and make sure you make a
profit that's 20 to 30 percent even 40
more than your total investment
but once
they set the price
that's the only price you can pay to
sell that drug
you still make 30 40 percent profit
after all your expenses you
demonstrate
and the other provision is you can't
increase
the price of that drug beyond the cost
of inflation
unless you've done additional work
on the drug to improve it
think about where we're going we're on
the we're on the verge
thank god
of some significant breakthroughs in
health care
but should it be based upon
what you can afford to pay
if congress acts
we could take care of things with a
stroke of a pen tomorrow
we have a generation of so-called
sandwich generation
many of you are part of it
trying to take care of your children
won't take care of your aging mom or dad
we can help make it work
care for early parents and have someone
install a handrail in the shower make
sure they have
steps that they can get up and down
someone can pick up the prescriptions
while you're working
and allow them to continue to live in
the dignity of their home
but guess what that saves a hell of a
lot of money
because the cost of that and by the way
that's available under medicare now
except 880 000 people don't can't get
into the program yet
it's a lot cheaper
to have mom and dad live at home with
those
minimal expense than have the public
pick up the cost of health care of uh of
housing
for the elderly
we can do that
and still save money
so when they put their heads in the
pillow at night they can have peace of
mind
i'm gonna work like the devil to bring
gas prices down
we're going to keep working the strength
of the supply chain and bring the cost
of every good down
particularly food
and automobiles but you know the best
news of all this
nobody
earning less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year
will pay an additional penny in taxes
for any of these services
we can do without increasing the deficit
matter of fact last year we reduced the
deficit by 300 billion dollars
but by passing the elements of the
buildback better plan which reduced the
burden on families
i got a letter from 17 nobel laureates
came to me to say this plan my plan will
ease long-term inflationary pressures
look we can tackle these challenges but
only if we keep coming
together the fact is we can't do it
without you
you understand what families are up
against
you understand the cost
if we fail to act
you need your voices the county
officials helping us under folks
understand what our communities need
if we can get this done there's no limit
to what america can achieve
so let's get
let's give working people
a better chance than they've had
quality they deserve by investing
in the future
of every county
let's face these challenges head on
but let's keep building back better
we're the only country in the world
where whatever crisis we've gone through
we've ended up on the other side better
off than we were before we got into the
crisis
we're the only one
and folks
[Applause]
let me say one other thing i had a group
of
eight major utilities come to see me
to tell me they wanted to see the
buildback better plan put in place
even though they knew they were going to
pay higher taxes corporate taxes would
go up to 24
you know there are of the major fortune
500 companies
there are 52 that made over 40 billion
dollars didn't pay a single penny
in tax
look i'm a capitalist
i know i think you should be able to go
out and make a million or a billion
dollars if you have the capability but
just pay
a little bit
pay your fair share
no i'm serious
i'm serious
and that's why we're getting so much
support
for the things we're doing
that's why for example and it's major
corporations coming to us
for example you ride through some fields
in iowa i mean excuse me ohio
and it looks like there's nothing there
except beautiful land stretched out well
guess what
and after call intel came to me and said
we want to invest
20 billion dollars in those fields
creating 7 600 jobs to build a facility
and 3 500 jobs permanent
average salary of those permanent jobs
135 000 a year you know what they're
doing they're going to make computer
chips
because our automobile is you know
one-third of inflation is a consequence
of the cost of automobiles going up
why they're going up
we invented the computer chip
but we don't make it
we have to get it from everyone from
taiwan to china to other places
look
we can do this
we can do this
by reasserting who in god's name we are
the united states of america there's
nothing i mean this from the bottom of
my heart
there's nothing beyond our capacity
there's nothing we cannot do
if we do it together that's always been
who we are
this is the united states of america
you can make a million bucks and still
pay your fair share and everybody when
have you ever seen i was talking to
somebody i said you know you go through
i'm a neighboring state in new jersey
from delaware my area is down by the
shore you're right through an
intersection where there's a big circle
and four or five roads coming off of it
and usually in the middle of that circle
there's plant you can you know you can
uh plant trees and flowers and like
i can tell you the communities and i
said this to somebody and then they
showed me a study that was true
i can tell you whether the community is
as renters
or owners
when they're owners
that middle circle is beautiful it's
planted
when they're renters they're not it
doesn't mean anything wrong with renting
but it means engaging in the community
look folks
when
middle class folks do well
there's never been a time the wealthy
don't do very very well
so folks
let's stick to the people we need
thank you for listening to me
may god bless you and may god protect
our troops thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]